welcome back this morning we have new
information following our report last
Saturday from inside the Secret Service
office investigating coronavirus related
scams on Friday Attorney General William
Barr urged the public to report these
suspected criminals the Attorney General
had already told US attorneys to
prioritize these scams and now the
Justice Department is recommending each
office establish a coronavirus fraud
coordinator joining us once again is CBS
News senior investigative correspondent
Catherine Harridge Catherine good
morning well good morning Dana what we
know since last week is through a senior
FBI official who told us here in
Washington that they have seen a
significant spike in Kovan 19 cyber
scams across the nation and what the
bureau anticipates is that these
criminals Dana will zero in on the
states with the highest rates of
infection Washington New York and
California and we also saw new evidence
this week that the criminals are
tracking the headlines the FBI revealed
to our investigative team that they're
seeing new scams involving government
relief checks as well as scams that are
targeting individuals who are working
from home and the maddening part about
this Catherine is that it the most
vulnerable population to coronavirus are
the ones who are being targeted by this
so that are getting hit both ways here
what what is the government doing right
now to stop it well one of the things
that we're seeing are increased warnings
from the federal government we had some
new images that were released this week
by Homeland Security to show how they
are interdicting what they believe to be
counterfeit test kits that are coming
into the United States these test kits
were intercepted at LAX Los Angeles
International Airport and then they were
handed over to the FDA the Food and Drug
Administration for review and then late
last night Jeff the FDA put out what
amounts to a national alert telling
people that they are seeing these
unauthorized test kits and they want the
bottom line to be for folks at home that
they haven't cleared anything so no
green light from the FDA for anyone to
sell these kits to folks to use for
testing at home Catherine do we have any
idea of how successful the scammers have
been so far
well we couldn't get a dollar figure
Dana from the FBI or the Secret Service
about the extent of the scams but I can
tell you from two decades of reporting
in this national security space that
when you have the Attorney General of
the United States coming out publicly
and urging folks at home to report these
scams and then mandating that US
Attorney's make it the highest priority
to prosecute these crimes and then you
have through our reporting here at CBS
News the Secret Service and the FBI so
forward-leaning that tells me that we
have a significant amount of scam
activity inside the United States that's
really hijack this theme of koban 19
Catherine what should people be doing
right now to help protect themselves
well Jeff it can be really overwhelming
for folks but I think there are a number
of things that you can do that are
pretty simple number one if you get
something that is unsolicited whether
it's a text message or an email or a
phone call with the Kovach 19 theme that
is an automatic red flag number two if
you get these messages and there's a
sense of urgency sort of a demand to act
immediately and to provide money upfront
either a deposit or phone payment that's
another red flag and the third thing is
that you can do your own reporting you
can be your own investigator if someone
calls you at home take their name ask
for their phone number sometime that's
simply enough to stop them in their
tracks and if you get that name and
phone number go on the web look up the
organization give them a call ask them
if this person is working for them and
if you get an email in your inbox that
looks like it might be official offering
you advice about koban 19 just take a
careful look at the address because
these scammers have addresses that look
real but it's usually off by at least
one letter or one numeral all right
Catherine said thanks very much and
anybody doing this not that they're
going to listen but knock it off here's
a sickening at this time